will hear with me to talk through what's
happening in Ukraine is the retired Air
Vice Marshal Sean Bell and Sean let's
talk about bag mode an awful lot of
fighting going on there a lot of focus
on this town why are the Russians
putting so much into this particular
town do you think yeah it's a great
question because the Russians are
clearly focused on taking the whole of
the donets region but bahut is a
relatively insignificant town from a
military perspective yet the Russians
seem to be expending an awful lot of
effort to undertake it part of the
answer lies in the fact that the Wagner
group The Mercenary group are the lead
for that operation in that area there's
about 50 000 troops about ten thousand
of their sort of contractors 40 000
convicts there they've also not short of
arms because they've just had an
assignment of Arms from North Korea
probably artillery shells but despite
all this man and material they're still
making very slow progress and huge
casualties part of the reason behind
that appears to be that the the guy
who's founded the the Barden group goes
in
um is very keen to demonstrate that his
group can actually do things on the
battlefield that this observing Russian
army cannot pringlesson has got his own
political Ambitions and he seems to be
quite prepared to sacrifice tens of
thousands of men in the pursuit of that
ambition on a slightly lighter note um
Admiral kazetnov which is the Russian
aircraft crowd it's the only one they've
got that went in to have some work done
about five years ago but in 2018 they
dry docked that it was mounted it was
the biggest Russia has
um sank and a 70 ton truck a crane was
on that collapsed onto the flight deck
of the aircraft carrier made a 200 odd
square foot hole in the flight deck ever
since then it's being under repair it
was within weeks of being returned to
the Russian Navy to be able to be their
Flagship again but we heard the other
day it caught fire and we're not quite
sure the extent of the damage but it
looks quite significant no suggestion at
this stage it's anything to do with the
ukrainians at all but it's a really good
example of the woes facing the Russian
military at the moment indeed and
meanwhile we've seen president zielinski
this week in Washington meeting
President Biden what does that visit at
achieved and what's it highlighted about
the approach that the U.S is taking as
opposed to the EU yeah I mean clearly
president zolensky is utterly reliant on
the flow of weapons and money from the
west and the alliance to the West is is
really critical zelenski went there for
a whole bunch of reasons but actually he
needs more weapons one of the at the
start of this conflict Ukraine was on
the defensive so they needed short-range
weapons anti-tack weapons that sort of
thing once they turn the tide and they
start getting on the offense they needed
longer range weapons so the Americans
provided high miles a 50 mile range so
they could Target behind the Enemy Lines
now as Ukraine wants to seize the
initiative and actually gain a bit more
momentum they America's look to offer
their attackers missile which is a 200
mile range missile the challenge of that
of course is that there are some EU
leaders that are really paranoid about
how that will get used because the
danger is it could get used to Target
Russian military facilities excuse me
actually in Russia itself and of course
that risks a grave escalation of the
conflict because if Putin alleges that
Russia is under attack the grave lit
risk of escalation there's no doubt
there'll be a lot of intensive
diplomatic conversations going on behind
the scenes at the moment yeah and and
meanwhile that we've seen that the Cozy
Fireside scenes there between President
zielinsky and President Biden how's that
been viewed in Russia has there been any
response from President Putin yes I mean
initially uh President Putin was very
dismissive about the um Patriot missiles
being launched he
um but of course he called it
provocation but the reality is that
these these Patriots are defensive
missiles they're designed to take out uh
ballistic missiles which were Russia was
using to Target civilian population but
now Putin's actually come out and
alluded to the fact these missiles might
not just be defensive they may have an
offensive name and also that the
ukrainians are and the US are extending
this war the reality is that there's a
lot of that's for domestic audience
we're not closing in on a deal anytime
soon okay Sean Bell thanks very much
indeed